author and columnist mark Stein who else
joins us tonight mark how's the shape of
your democracy tonight well sometimes
it's shaped like a sausage and egg
McMuffin and at other times it's shaped
like Scarlett Johansson in that cute
little outfit she wears in the Avengers
but unless it's one of those two it
doesn't really when I when I trying to
hear the voice of the people
they don't seem exercised about it shape
generally unless it's like the air
sausage and egg McMuffin or the Scarlett
Johansson in the cute little Avengers
getup by the way has the applause died
down yet for mayor Pete's line about
needing to build the future that's
better than the past so is it still
ringing in our ears I think I heard the
fake sound of someone going woo on tape
at an episode of I Love Lucy in 1956
that they managed to add it onto the end
of mayor Pete speech say it's
fantastically impressive I should just
say for audience watching at home you
never have the questions ahead of time
since all the fastest person on
television so let me just ask you do you
think the people around Pete Buddha
judge he just hired a new advisor from
Goldman Sachs do you think they're
clever enough to convince the country
that this is a real candidate and not
some kind of corporate hologram well I
think corporate hologram is right I've
never seen any candidate who is so poll
tested and focus-grouped as this one and
it's interesting to me that the people
who this is the first millennial to run
for president and according to how you
slice it he may or may not have won the
Iowa caucus and he's in with a sporting
chance
they're doing the same in New Hampshire
and yet it's actually with with younger
voters he is incredibly unpopular and
and interestingly to me because everyone
talks about identity politics this guy
ought to be romping home on that front
because as we know he's gay and his
husband would be the first First
Gentleman in the White House but the
younger the Millennials and Generation Z
don't like him because in a shorthand I
guess he's a gay square he might as well
be Joe Biden zip it up into some kind of
youthful bodysuit and it's interesting
to me that young voters know the gay
thing doesn't Trump the for them the
fact that he's not radical enough on the
policy and that's actually quite
interesting on how identity politics
doesn't even play with the Millennial
crowd no nobody likes it nobody likes
woke Nisour like 11 people on Twitter
and all of them live in Brooklyn they're
holding the country hostage and
everybody secretly hates them so if he
does in the end win the New Hampshire
primary and Bernie just kind of
disappears or all the votes or you know
stole it and then return are people
gonna buy this I don't think so I mean I
think he runs into some pretty severe
problems once he gets to South Carolina
for when the internal contradictions of
the rainbow coalition as marks might
have put it will come into play very
interestingly and that's why you get
this nutty talk about Bloomberg and
maybe even drafting MIT Romney now now
he's the the holiest person on the
planet so they're so they're still
looking for their dream candidate and
this guy isn't really cutting it for
them but I'm enjoying the heck out of it
the great works know yes so much
thanks a lot Tucker